oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui un témoignage fort
sur le deuil d'un fils stéphane
albertini tombés sous les balles au
bataclan le 13 novembre 2015 je reçois
jean pierre albertini son père auteur
d'un livre mourir au bataclan aux
éditions mareuil bonjour jean pierre
albertini merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors évidemment la parution
de votre livre coïncide avec le
déroulement d'un procès historique qui
est très douloureux pour les nombreuses
parties civiles dont vous êtes 1,2200
parties civiles au total une vraie honte
de choc un procès des attentats au cours
duquel vont être jugés salle abdeslam et
ses complices comment abordez vous cette
épreuve vous êtes vous rendu au procès
oui effectivement
au début je pensais ne pas y aller ne
pas assister parce qu'ayant perdu notre
fils j'estimais que nous n'avions pas
grand chose à en attendre que ce procès
ne ferait pas revenir est mort
et puis en parlant avec d'anciens
d'anciennes victimes avec les
associations j'ai découvert que celles
qui étaient allés dans des procès
précédents
c'était obligé en quelque sorte à y
aller et une fois qu'elle avait fait 7 7
et fort qu'elle avait suivi cette
nouvelle épreuve elle n'avait pas
regretté et donc sur leurs conseils je
suis allé aux premières auditions du
procès et effectivement je ne regarde
pas du tout qu'est ce que vous y trouvez
alors vous à titre personnel parce que
je pense que chaque partie civile y
trouve quelque chose en particulier
alors moi si vous voulez j'ai été
j'étais vraiment extrêmement ému par et
les deux que président appelle des
dépositions et que moi j'appellerai des
témoignages
aussi bien d'ailleurs des forces de
l'ordre que des premiers témoins du
carillon et du stade de france et j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait
pour parler peut-être du côté plus
difficile est ce que vous avez entendu
ou vous a reporté les paroles de salles
abdeslam qui continue à se revendiquer
combattants de l'état islamique qui a
également dit que le 13 novembre était
inévitable à cause des bombardements sur
la syrie de françois hollande c'est pas
la provocation de trop moi je suis
heureux que salades des sables est
ouvert la bouche oui c'est déjà quelque
chose c'est déjà gardé le silence depuis
six ans voilà c'est déjà un progrès
parce que au moins ils posent dès le
début sa ligne de défense absolument
alors est ce qu'elle est acceptable ou
pas
à la fois je pense qu'il joue sur deux
tableaux il joue à la fois sur le fait
que c'est un musulman purée radical et
en même temps il rend responsable le
gouvernement français de l'époque ils
jouent sur ces deux aspects et ça montre
un peu ça de toute façon cette duplicité
et en fait je pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui a loupé sa vie et qui a raté sa mort
aussi
donc il cherche à se défendre comme mais
comme il veut là on va revenir votre
livre mourir au bataclan qui est un
immense message d'amour pour la personne
formidable qui était votre fils stéphane
d'ailleurs à l'époque des attentats on
se souvient que on entendait beaucoup
parler de lui de cette figure de la vie
parisienne en egypte et le directeur du
restaurant chez dit viau à neuilly un
restaurant qui était très couru et
malheureusement des morts avec son
associé son ami pierre innocenti qui
sont tombés tous les deux associés en
même temps c'était un homme solaire
votre fils on voit dans ceux d'hier un
homme généreux un homme enthousiaste
mais c'est cultiver drôle et c'est un
papa aussi les hommages à l'époque se
sont multipliées je me souviens encore
de voir son visage sur des réseaux
sociaux et aujourd'hui ça votre tour de
vis rendre hommage de célébrer sa
mémoire avec ce livre oui en fait
pendant les mois qui ont suivi
le 13 novembre
c'était tellement douloureux on était
vraiment dans la courbe descendante de
dans la partie descendant de la courbe
de deuil et donc j'étais incapable de de
prendre une quelconque décision et il y
avait les pleure tous les jours toutes
les nuits de façon continuelle et ce qui
s'est passé c'est que le 13 novembre
19 dont quatre ans après le drame
c'était un mercredi et ce matin là comme
tous les 13 novembre il y avait les
hommages et les commémorations devant le
le bataclan notamment et donc le matin
j'ai assisté aux commémorations et à 14
heures nous avions rendez vous avec le
fils de stéphane notre petit fils comme
tous les mercredis
et quand je suis arrivé ce jour là sa
nounou et dior il est pas très content
aujourd'hui alors j'ai joué un peu naïf
j'ai dit mais c'est mercredi c'est le
jour où on va pas l'école c'est le jour
des vacances et non non non c'est pas ça
c'est le jour c'est le jour des papiers
des mamies non et puis il avait les
larmes aux yeux et l'a dit non c'est le
jour où papa est mort
100 ha
c'était tellement douloureux à la fois
pour lui pour sa nounou pour moi
je me suis dit en fait qu'est-ce qui
connaît de l'histoire de son père il
avait 4 ans à l'époque il en a 10
aujourd'hui
et je me suis dit faut absolument que
j'écrive l'histoire de son père la vie
de famille avant comment son père était
vim et voilà et donc je suis rentré chez
moi j'ai commencé à écrire
a rédigé la première page c'est à dire
l'annnonce de la mora
à ce petit garçon
je raconte dans le livre d'ailleurs qui
a été une épreuve très douloureuse et
puis de fil en aiguille j'ai écrit
évidemment la nuit du drame en détail du
moins ce qu on en a appris au fur et à
mesure parce que ce n'est qu'au fur et à
mesure des mois qu'on a appris le détail
alors voilà oui oui parce qu'en fait
comme je le dis dans le livre quand on
nous a dit l'institut médico légal que
notre fils y était
on a eu quinze minutes pour solder 39 39
années de devis en fait et on ne savait
même pas de quoi il était mort ni
comment naît en quête de constance et
donc effectivement j'ai commencé à
chercher
ce qui s'était passé dans les dernières
minutes
justement dans ce livre on se rend bien
compte vous témoigner de toutes les
difficultés endurées par les victimes
blessées bien sûr les et aussi les
proches qui ont perdu un être aimé mais
qui sont confrontés à un véritable
calvaire comme par exemple on va on va
en parler mais les plateformes
téléphoniques pour savoir ce qu'ils
étaient devenus les disparus étaient
injoignables
vous ne savez pas comment votre fils est
mort vous devez enquêter sur tout et
vous confronter à des horreurs
finalement oui mais déjà déjà les jours
le 13 14 15 et jours suivants novembre
2015 en réalité le soir du 13 novembre
il n'y avait que ça sans sa compagne qui
savait qu'il était au bataclan sa
compagne et leur fils habite et en plus
au dessus du restaurant où ils
travaillent et donc travaillé nuit et
jour dans ce restaurant et c'était quand
même presque une vocation en fait il
était très pris dans cette affaire là et
donc à part sa femme personne ne savait
qu'il était là et il l'avait il avait
deux soeurs sa soeur aînée s'était
mariée au mois d'août était donc parti
en voyage de noces du 11 au 22 novembre
et avait laissé ses enfants donc
à la mère de stéphane et
il avait choisi en fait une un pays où
on leur avait dit qu'ils avaient pas de
risque terroriste ce qui était quand
même assez incroyable parce que l'année
2015 était quand même très marquées par
des attentats donc sa soeur aînée était
en tanzanie et donc sa mère garder les
enfants de sa fille aînée est ma
deuxième fille donc la soeur cadette de
stéphane habitait à l'époque à côté de
la dgs y est donc elle a entendu les
sirènes ont sonné dans la rue de
villiers mais elle s'est dit bon cette
année c'est une année où il ya beaucoup
de sirène
mais avant de se coucher elle a allumé
la télévision et elle a commencé à voir
évidemment les bandeaux et les scènes
d'horreur elle se branche sur son
facebook et là elle découvre que
stéphane était au bataclan alors en fait
toute la nuit avec la compagne de
stéphane elles ont essayé de savoir ce
qu'ils étaient devenus parce
qu'évidemment il ne répondait pas ils
étaient partis à quatre et deux sont
morts et de son revenu voilà et autant
donc stéphane était avec son son ami
d'enfance y aussi qui était son patron
un
chai livio il était aussi avec un couple
le couple a réussi à sortir et
lalem la compagne qui a dit moi j'ai vu
pierre décédé mais stéphane je ne sais
pas ce qu'il est devenu et donc
nous avons enterré stéphane deux
semaines après le 13 novembre sans
savoir dans quelles circonstances il
était décédé puisqu'il avait disparu de
son groupe d'amis votre fils a pu sortir
du bataclan il a même croisé un des
membres du groupe
bien sûr la chaussée il est décédé on
l'a retrouvé que le lendemain comment
alors c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé au fur et à mesure j'ai réussi à
reconstituer
plus ou moins d'ailleurs parce que c'est
pas toujours fait pas encore totalement
clair
dans un premier temps j'ai appris qu'il
n'avait pas été retrouvés dans la salle
du bataclan mais dans le bureau
administratif du bataclan quai au numéro
56 boulevard voltaire alors que le
bataclan et aux 50 donc il ya six
numéros d'écart et entre les deux il ya
notamment ce fameux passage saint-pierre
amelot où on a vu tant de victimes
s'échapper par l'issue de secours dans
un premier temps on a appris qu'on
l'avait retrouvée dans ce local
deuxièmement il était seul
il a été transporté ali mails le samedi
après-midi 14 novembre
ski l'institut médico-légal n'ont à
l'institut médico-légal et
c'est tout ce qu'on savait
donc un jour tout à fait par hasard je
regarde internet et je vois que un
rescapé guitariste du bataclan avait
fait un clip est une chanson qu'il avait
dédié spécifiquement à stéphane à la fin
dans son générique de fin il ya bien
dédié à stéphane et à toutes les
victimes
et donc je me renseigne je vois quoi
ressemble et captain boogie et le 13
novembre suivant lors des commémorations
deux ans le bataclan je m'approche de
lui et je lui dis est ce que vous êtes
bien captain boogie me dit oui pourquoi
et je trouvais pas je trouve pas les
mots et soudain il m'a pris dans ses
bras et m'a dit oh non non et il a
compris ma dit
oui je comprends et je lui ai dit mais
expliquez moi et là j'ai eu un un
élément d'information
il m'a expliqué qu'en fait lui même été
sorti par cette issue de secours qui
était au coin de saint pierre amelot et
du boulevard voltaire que stéphane était
allongé par terre il savait qu'il était
blessé il a eu le temps ou juste lui
donner son nom
mais captain bout il a oublié parce
qu'en fait ayant fait du sauvetage et de
secourisme l'ensemble de sa jeunesse en
fait il voulait s'occuper du maximum de
personnes et donc il a demandé à
certaines personnes occupez vous de lui
et à partir de là il sait pas ce qu'il
est devenu et donc
on l'a retrouvé effectivement dans ce
local administratif du bataclan
et
tard un jour à la télévision je vois
deux lors d'une émission
une dame qui dit j'habitais dans
l'immeuble du bureau du bataclan
après les attaques je suis descendu pour
voir des gens qui travaillaient et
collaborateurs du bataclan et au lieu de
trouver l'équipe je me suis retrouvé
seul dans ce local avec un jeune homme
dont je ne savais pas quel était son
état
je suis remonté dans les étages pour
essayer de trouver quelqu'un qui vienne
m'aider qui viennent me dire qu en
est-il parce que moi j'étais incapable
de de définir sa situation est-ce qu'il
était décédé mourant mans est en fait
personne n'a voulu descendre
seule porte qui s'est ouverte c'était au
dernier étage s'était
la gardienne de l'immeuble qui a bien
voulu ouvrir qui faisaient une réception
avec une dizaine personnes
et en fait
seul n'a voulu descendre parce que à la
télévision envoyez que le quartier était
quand même
massacré et on disait qu'il y avait
peut-être déjà dit ce qui était sur les
toits où personne n'a voulu descendre
donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui je sais
comment il est sorti je sais où on l'a
retrouvé mais il ya une incertitude sur
les personnes qui donc transporter du de
la chose de la chaussée
du passage saint-pierre amelot jusque
dans ce local donc une véritable enquête
que vous avez dû mener seule file seul
jean pierre albertini nous allons
marquer une courte pause on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
jean pierre albertini tia signer ce
livre mourir au bataclan aux éditions
mareuil pour rendre hommage à son fils
stéphane albertini décédé au bataclan
lors des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
alors jean pierre albertini vous parlez
donc de ces épreuves qui se sont ajoutés
à ce deuil épouvantable notamment le
protocole déshumanisé de l'institut
médico légal vous avez 15 minutes devant
un fils sans pouvoir le toucher oui
alors effectivement lorsque le dimanche
matin on nous a confirmé qu'il était un
institut médico légal moi j'étais en
provence
j'étais parti là-bas pour
fêter les 96 ans de ma mère donc je suis
revenu immédiatement à paris
la mère de stéphane aussi qui gardait
les enfants de notre fille aînée
immédiatement à paris et moi le lundi je
suis allé avec la jeune soeur de
stéphane à l'institut médico-légal et
l'on là ça a été effectivement une
journée extrêmement douloureuse parce
que les les familles de victimes
commençaient à affluer donc nous étions
très nombreux et il y avait un service
d'ordre et de dead psychologique et donc
il y avait beaucoup de bd bénévoles qui
étaient vraiment très très aidant est
très
très agréable mais c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on lui a demandé si on avait
besoin d'une aide psychologique moi j'ai
dit m'écouter j'étais tellement
tellement en colère j'ai dit mais non
l'aide psychologique c'est pas nous qui
avons besoin c'est ces fous qui ont fait
ces actes odieux et on a attendu jusqu'à
16 heures et enfin en fin d'après midi
on a pu enfin rentrer dans le bâtiment
qui était sinistre et là ça a été un
dédale de couloirs de documents bien sûr
on nous a donné des informations
administratives mais c'est tout et in
fine et nous avons vu une psychologue
qui nous a dit voilà vous avez 15
minutes
et ce sera derrière une vitre et là je
dois dire que ça a été le jour le plus
épouvantable d'une vie c'est 6 voilà
j'ai entendu les autres témoignages
c'est pareil pour tout le monde il ya
autre chose qui est très critiquée par
aller participer par les victimes c'est
le parcours administratif notamment la
question de l'indemnisation et des
expertises alors vous avez dû
certainement à y passer aussi tout comme
votre famille accompagnent de oui alors
pour nous si vous voulez c'était
relativement simple à partir du moment
où stéphane était décédé il n'y avait
pas
deux sujets de comment dire de
convalescence de 2,2 de chirurgie et de
et de consignation à terme donc si ça
n'allait pas durer sur des années parce
que j'ai cru comprendre que les gens qui
sont blessés c'est vraiment le parcours
du combattant illégal de dire d'ailleurs
entre nous et
dont nous stéphane étant décédé
en réalité si pour être précis en fait
il y a deux catégories d'indemnisation
il y à l'indemnisation
dit affective qui est en fait selon un
barème selon le lien de sang que vous
avez ou le lien familial que vous avez
avec la victime c'est un catalogue de
mon temps et c'est ça n'est pas
discutable voilà et il ya l'autre partie
qui est la partie économique dont la
majorité de la famille de stéphane avait
pas besoin puisque moi j'étais à la
retraite les deux soeurs de stéphane
travailler et est indépendant il y avait
que sa compagne qui était concerné par
cet aspect là et donc elle a
effectivement été dédommagés en ce qui
concernait non seulement l'aspect
affectif l'aspect moral là la pression
de lorie en quelque sorte et de l'autre
côté la partie économique mais je sais
que pour les gens qui sont blessés avec
des blessures graves aussi bien
d'ailleurs physique que psychique cc
c'est l'horreur quoi moi une forme j'ai
rencontré le dirigeant de du fgti lors
d'une commémoration il me disait venez
venez me voir tulle allait devoir
c'était une époque où les avocats
avaient réussi à faire
sauf garantie voila voila mais pas
seulement les victimes d'attentats
d'ailleurs les victimes de le tout seul
voilà d'accident la route et
et c'était une époque où les avocats
avaient réussi à obtenir un
dédommagement très modeste et qui
s'appelait
le préjudice d'attentes c'est à dire que
si vous ne saviez pas si votre proche
était mort
on vous donnait quelque chose comme le
4000 euros quoi et bien sûr jour là
c'était 48 heures voilà parce qu'elles
étaient restés 48 ans sans savoir ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la sdb sexualité hopitalisés été nulle
part mais il n'était pas le seul un la
clk qui s'est reproduit plusieurs fois
et on m'arrête ici sans regarder ils ont
dit ah ben non le conseil
d'administration a dit qu' il fallait
que la victime habite sous le même toit
que les personnes qui demandent comme
s'il fallait habiter sous le même toit
pour avoir attendu toute la nuit et
jusqu'au dimanche suivant pour savoir ce
qu'il en était voilà donc moi je vous
donne cet exemple là parce que c'est
celui que j'ai rencontré et pour vous
dire la vérité je n'ai toujours pas
signé la proposition qui m'a été fait
j'ai ce sentiment affreux de me dire le
jour où je signe
signer la mort de mon fils et ça c'est
insupportable
voilà je crois qu'on a 10 ans pour
accepter
si vous perdez votre enfant quel est le
prix ça n'a pas de prix voilà alors on
dit la france est très bien organisée
le fonds de garantie est alimenté par
vos contrats d'assurance on vous prend
3,5 5 euros 90 sur chaque contrat
automobile et appartements habitations
donc tout le monde participe à ça mais
un enfant ça n'a pas de prix c'est le
don du ciel que je sais pas il faut être
faut être fou malade pour s'attaquer des
enfants quel que soit leur âge
malgré l'horreur que vous avez vécu est
ce qu'aujourd'hui avec ce livre
notamment est peut-être un autre
parcours que vous faites on peut encore
parler de résilience pour votre famille
et vous est ce qu'on peut vivre malgré
cette douleur
je crois effectivement que
l'un des remèdes c'est déjà le temps est
ce que le temps quand même fait son
oeuvre
c'est une oeuvre qui malheureusement
sera jamais parfaite
donc c'est vrai que face à ça on peut
avoir plusieurs attitudes je connais des
gens qui se sont laissées mourir ou qui
se sont
supprimés c'est arrivé d'autres qui ont
une telle colère qui n'arrive pas
accepter la société telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et si vous êtes entre les
deux extrêmes il faut bien faire appel à
toutes les aides qu'on vous propose donc
il y a les associations de victimes qui
sont extrêmement importante parce que
notamment celles qui sont comme l'avait
été la fenvac qui sont
d'anciennes l'association et qui donc
ont déjà une expérience de ces
moments-là douloureux bon il ya deux
autres qui ont été créés et si vous
voulez les autres avaient une
antériorité qu'on n'avait pas celle là
et donc il y aller les associations de
victimes
évidemment il ya l'aide et psychologique
il ya les groupes de parole est à la
fois puisque moi j'ai vu des témoignages
de parents qui avaient perdu leurs deux
filles leurs deux uniques filles qui ont
écrit un livre aussi et qui ont fait des
témoignages bouleversants sur l'aide de
la foi
et puis en ce qui me concerne je crois
que suis pas le seul il ya l'écriture
aussi est autant quand j'ai écrit à la
fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane des voyages et des bons moments
de vie et de lumière
en même temps c'était très douloureux et
puis aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que
ça permettait d'une certaine manière de
d'extraire de moi même toute cette
histoire est donc ça m'a apporté un peu
de recul un peu d'apaisement mais là de
la douleur et la colère seront là
jusqu'à ma mort je je sais que le jour
de ma mort sur le mon lit de mort
que je verrai ce sera le visage de
stéphane
je le sais
vous parlez de cette colère que qu'on
entend dans votre livre bien sûr vous
formulez de nombreuses remarques sur
l'état par exemple l'état qui n'a pas su
endiguer le terrorisme sur son
territoire selon vous je vais vous citer
alors vous dit ce jour là la france n'a
pas été en mesure de défendre ses
citoyens et a failli à ses obligations
toutes les précautions n'ont pas été
prises selon vous c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est l' enquête parlementaire qui
est extrêmement bien
réalisée qui est extrêmement détaillé
moi j'ai lu donc seulement le rapport
mais j'ai lu les auditions de toutes les
parties prenantes un tous les ministres
tous les chefs de la berri du raid les
responsables judiciaires de
pénitentiaire et tout ça
c'est une évidence qu'une évidence qui a
eu des ratés essentiellement d'ailleurs
au niveau du renseignement oui
oui oui mais bien sûr mais ces dix dès
la mi daoud qui était un des cerveaux
qui était recherché pourtant et ce alors
c'était c'était plus précisément l'un
des trois l'un des trois assaillants du
bataclan qui était sous contrôle
judiciaire et qui ne respectaient pas je
laisse balader
abdeslam aussi il est allé je crois une
dizaine de fois
du côté de la turquie dans les autres
racault syrienne et et voilà donc un
manque de coordination du renseignement
à la en france d'abord entre dgse et
dgsi ensuite à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen
et puis bien sûr aussi avec les pays
comme l'egypte et d'autres pays
du moyen-orient et pourtant ce qui est
le comble c'est que vous parlez de cette
cellule interministérielle des deux
victimes du terrorisme qui a été mise en
place un jour avant les apports wii a
été mise en place la veille je pense
qu'au plus haut niveau on avait des
informations qui montrait d'ailleurs
qu'il y allait se passer quelque chose
de grave mais on ne savait pas quand on
ne savait pas où
bien sûr il y avait beaucoup d'indicés 1
qui orientés vers des salles de
spectacles vers vers le bataclan
notamment puisque en 2019
pardon en 2009 exactement il y avait
déjà eu quelqu'un qui avait été arrêté
qui était allée en egypte qui était
revenu et sa compagne avait dit qu'il
voulait attaquer le bataclan mais faute
de preuves et faute sans doute de
coordination entre les pays belgique
egypte et france grèce même il n'a pas
pu être à are et enfin emprisonnés et
donc on a retrouvé dans les assassinats
du
du 13 novembre
voilà donc y avait des défaillances au
niveau du renseignement au niveau
évidemment pénitentiaire puisque ce que
vous vous dites que ya pas de
surveillance suffisante en prison là où
peuvent se font remonter de déjà les
attentats ou à localiser des voilà voilà
il ya même des témoignages de deux
députés qui sont allés visiter des
prisons qui fait qu'ils étaient
complètement
estomaqué de voir qu'il y avait des
cellules qui ressemblait plutôt à des
mosquées ou à des lieux de prière cas
des
cas des lieux de prison ou même des
des accusés qui avaient signé un acte et
le
le juge croyait qu'il signait sa
dépouille est en fait il y faisait il
déclaré en fait sur le coran leur ca
comment dire enfin sa profession de foi
donc
faiblesse là je pense qu'elles étaient
connus au plus haut niveau mais la
réelle mesure de la menace n'était pas
prise au sérieux alors vous à a
posteriori vous critiquez aussi le fait
qu'au nom des libertés individuelles on
est tardé à mettre en place des lois
pour freiner le terrorisme pour mieux le
repérer dans maintenance a quand même
été corrigé par de nouvelles
dispositions oui contre le terrorisme
oui c'est un peu tard c'est suffisant en
tout cas c'est jamais trop tard pour
bien faire un
c'est nécessaire mais comme je dis comme
comme le le procès lui-même c'est
nécessaire mais pas suffisant c'est
nécessaire en ce sens que les coupables
de ce drame seront punis et j'espère
qu'ils seront punis sévèrement j'espère
que leurs peines ne seront effectivement
réalisé
j'espère aussi qu'à travers le l'enquète
et l'instruction on découvrira comment
fonctionner ces réseaux bon alors
maintenant que
le prétendu état islamique n'a plus de
territoire il est plus diffus la menace
est plus diffuse donc lui faire de
manière plus difficile à endiguer sur
des petits attentats mais tout aussi
meurtriers et
moi ce que je j'estime que en fait à
partir du moment où des gens comme ça se
réclament d'une guerre
et quand même que que la menace est
planétaire en quelque sorte un l et ol
et au moyen-orient mais elle s'étend
vers l'asie elle s'étend vers l'afrique
il me semble qu'il faudrait un procès
international qui jugent tous ces crimes
parce que ce sont des crimes contre
l'humanité c'est presque génocidaire
puisque c'est clairement qu'entre les
noms
parties prenantes à cette idéologie et
puis je crois quand même que
que les pays
[Musique]
musulmans honteux travail à faire parce
que quand j'ai vu hier certains
témoignages de musulmans qui ont été
blessés dans leur chair ou dans le rhode
ou dans leur cerveau j'ai vu des
témoignages mais
incroyable d'humanité qui disait mais ça
n'est pas ça notre religion et il
pouvait le dire parce que derrière la
vitre il avait ce qu'il appelait des
frères un loyer il y avait des gens qui
ont été blessées au stade de france ou
au carillon qui était qu'ils sont
musulmans et qu'ils disent mais mais
mais ce sont nos frères mais mais c'est
pas ça lorsqu'on a appris dans les
quartiers ils ont vécu leur enfance avec
ces gens là et donc moi je pense que la
ligne de partage n'est pas entre les
musulmans et les non-musulmans la ligne
de partage est à l'intérieur
de deux là aux mains il faut absolument
que à l'intérieur du monde musulman
suscitent s'il existe non musulmans que
on arrive à faire la part des choses
entre les musulmans qui sont
aptes et qui veulent vivre avec des pays
démocratiques et puis ceux qui sont en
fait des assassins et quelles que soient
leurs idéologies
acceptable ou condamnable il faut
vraiment
je n'aime pas les politiques qui disent
à vous attaquer les musulmans non c'est
pas vrai c'est pas vrai il y a chez les
musulmans des gens qui quittent eux qui
sont victimes et qui ne peuvent plus
supporter
mais bien sûr
c'est bien sûr mais à l'intérieur 10
lames on voit qu'il ya une très grande
difficulté à se mettre d'accord très
grande difficulté entre les sunnites les
chiites
même entre les imams regarder notre
notre gouvernement a essayé d'avoir une
charte des principes
de l'islam de france
sur les neuf sur les neuf participants
trois ont refusé de signer
on n'arrive toujours pas à voir le co ce
fameux conseil national des imams qui
serait justement une manière de
d'endiguer cette idéologie mortifère on
a du mal à y arriver mais
il faut il faut avec le temps qu'on y
arrive je remercie beaucoup ce sera le
mot de la fin monsieur albertini donc
jean pierre albertini venu nous parler
de son fils mort au bataclan mourir au
bataclan c'est votre livre aux éditions
au maroc vous êtes vous l'avez ici aussi
écrit en mémoire pour les victimes du 13
novembre vous vous rendez vous la rendez
hommage également bien sûr vous pourrez
retrouver cette émission en intégralité
sur rtl france point tv merci pour votre
fidélité à bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]